eldon ring it's the biggest game of the
year it's the latest entry in from
software's a masochistic mega series of
action rpgs set in dead ruined worlds
full of monsters wanna kick you in the
teeth and it's got a lot of people
asking one question should i play eldon
ring well i played elden ring but should
you play eldon right well after taking a
vacation from this job for an entire
week to do nothing to play the game i
think i can help you answer that
question
[Music]
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications because believe me it is
the only way you can become an elden
award so is elden ring right for you
well if you've played or enjoyed any of
from software's previous dark souls
games or bloodborne or the kingsfield
series if you're a truly insane turbo
masochist then you probably don't need
to ask yourself anything if you like
dark souls already elden ring is
definitely the game for you if you're
anything like me you'll probably have a
few issues with it mostly pertaining to
the open world but you are gonna like it
because it's just like the other dark
souls games but way bigger you're not
going from small interconnected zone to
small interconnected zone there is
pretty much nothing in this game like
the mostly straight path from firelink
shrine to anor londo in dark souls 1.
instead all the castles ruins and
forests that you love bashing your head
against are sprinkled around a truly
massive map and if you're having trouble
with one you can just run across the map
and go to another now sometimes this
huge map does get in the way of the game
being the dark souls you might want it
to be if you just want to do the content
that feels like from software's older
games you're going to spend a lot of
time running around between that stuff
on the open world and it might feel a
little frustrating that said when this
game hits both in the open world and in
the traditional dark souls style legacy
dungeons it [ __ ] hits but if you have
never played a souls game and want to
know if you should try elden ring or if
you did play souls games didn't like
them and now you're feeling some intense
fomo because everyone on your steam list
is 40 hours into their adventure in the
lands between
let me try to sell you on the game a
little bit so to start if you like just
the idea of a challenging action rpg
that doesn't really hold your hand
i think you should just check out elden
ring without asking any more questions
there is a real satisfaction from
triumphing over this game's challenges
to go back to the challenge thing elden
ring respects your intelligence and
skill as a player and it's not going to
throw stuff at you that's impossible but
it's also not going to throw anything
super easy at you nothing feels as good
as triumphing over this game's
challenges and in terms of the open
world elden ring doesn't have any
waypoints or quest markers or really
many collectibles beyond important items
weapons and crafting materials this is
not a game that is telling you where to
go or what to do basically at any time
in that way it's really different from
modern open world action games like
assassin's creed or far cry those games
are often defined by checklist of chores
that the devs think you might enjoy
doing while playing the game elden ring
pretty much leaves all that decision
making up to you and whatever you see on
the horizon that might look cool to
explore in that way it's a lot like
breath of the wild another truly
incredible open world game that left all
the content finding and path making up
to you as the player it's really good
stuff for example i really struggled
with the game's first story boss so i
explored the open world instead of
bashing my head against him some more
that way i ended up going into an area
that was leading to one of the game's
end game zones and my level 20 ass was
pushing up against level 50 content and
doing mostly fine by playing smart and
using all the cool tools i was picking
up another awesome moment i had in the
open world was actually in that near
endgame zone i was wandering around i
saw a windmill and a bunch of women
dancing around a bonfire near it i
approached because i saw an item in the
bonfire and it was actually the
nobleman's armor set these ladies were
burning a rich dude alive and as soon as
i pulled his clothes and weapon out of
the fire their eyes turned red they
pulled out pitchforks and torches and
they started attacking me not only that
but a bunch of burning skeletons rose up
from the bonfire and started attacking
me too specifically by exploding at me
for huge damage it was a really cool
moment my last little cool moment that
i'll share with you that hopefully
convinces you that this game is really
something special and worth trying is a
cheese strap i found that is really
really cool i ended up being a level 50
character in a level 80 near endgame
zone because i killed a boss using the
rot status ailment i inflicted him with
rot and then walked away as the poison
slowly killed him i had no business
meeting this boss and yet i did it
because this game really lets you do
anything you want and before you worry
that all this fun freely exploration
gets ruined by how hard everyone says
this game is i'm here to tell you that
eldon ring does not have to be that
difficult if you don't want it to be
there are a lot of invisible difficulty
switches you can flip if you want to
make the game easier for you and you
shouldn't let anyone tell you that
you're playing the game wrong for using
them so now that you hopefully agree
with me that elden ring is a really cool
game that you should check out because
it's so unique and interesting and fun
let me share some tips with you on how
to make the play experience a little
less bumpy as you're starting out
starting out with the fact that there is
a secret tutorial right here jump down
this hole i promise i know it looks
deadly but there is a tutorial down
there it'll teach you all about combat
including all the new things added to
this game the previous from soft games
didn't have like guard counters for
example before you go into tutorial
though you'll have to pick a class you
can't really go wrong here but you
definitely shouldn't pick wretch it's
really hard for a new player meanwhile
samurai and astrologer are really great
choices for a first timer as for
keepsakes mostly two options for a
beginner golden seed if you want extra
heals or fanged imp ashes if you want a
bit of an easier time fighting bosses
now once you've done all that the most
important thing you can do is follow the
golden arrows on your map leading from
sight of grace to sight of grace i
believe once you hit for them you'll
meet molina who is going to give you a
horse which is very important and teach
you how to level up from there you could
go to fight the first main boss margaret
i'm not ashamed to tell you i didn't
beat him until i was level 23. he is
hard instead of bashing your head
against him you should do some exploring
there's lots of stuff to do in limb
grave and you will get lots of levels
while doing it you can actually go and
do the entire second main dungeon before
beating market and honestly i kind of
think that dungeon is easier so maybe
it's a good choice speaking of exploring
the first and most important thing you
should be doing in any area in the game
is getting the map fragment the first
one is right here but if you open your
map after entering a new area you can
actually see where the map fragment is
hanging out eldering puts a lot of stuff
directly on the map so make sure to keep
checking it and the last tip i can give
you is to please use summons and ashes
of war when you need them they will make
bosses easier if you're having trouble
and it is not wrong to make use of that
i know lots of people will say that
using these mechanics isn't playing the
game as intended but [ __ ] those people
do whatever you need to do to make this
game fun for you that's what playing
games is about anyway i think eldon ring
is a fantastic game and if you've made
it all the way to the end of this video
i think you'll enjoy it too it is really
cool and unique and it lets you play
however you want it is not as daunting
as some people say it is if that's
what's scaring you off plus no other
game has a turtle pope gonna look at
this dude he's awesome
the weirdest thing that happened to me
is that so there's a lot of churches
around the game that are churches like
it's a very i assume to like various
deities in the game's mythology
there's a lot of george rr martin ass
[ __ ] in here one of them is the church
of irit i-r-i-t-h which is my mom's name
and she spells it really specifically
with the th even because it's just like
kind of close to the way that you might
spell it in hebrew and
that's exactly like that in this game
and it really threw me off i had to send
her a picture it [ __ ] me up it was so
weird